David, given the fiasco with Trump not conceding,
should presidential transitions really depend
on an administration official of the sitting
president like Emily Murphy at the GSA? This is
a great question. The framework for the official
transition is outlined by the Presidential
Transition Act of 1963. And insofar as that
outlines the official piece of the transition the
General Service Administration had, Emily Murphy
was the person who had to authorize about seven
million dollars in funds to be made available
to Joe Biden to officially start the transition.
Now, in a sense, the transition doesn't really
depend on her. And what I mean by that is
the GSA had, as directed by Trump, doesn't really
need to do anything in order for Joe Biden to be
president and sworn in on January 20th. These
are separate processes. What the GSA process
does is it recognizes the current administration
sees the president elect as the president elect.
We are freeing up funding. It greases the wheels
for starting to give Joe Biden the presidential
daily briefing and facilitating some other
things. But either way, on January 20th,
Trump stops being president and the Supreme Court
chief justice swears in the new president. It
doesn't actually depend on the GSA. That being
said, I do believe that at this point in time,
listen, the explanation that Emily Murphy gave
was I'm supposed to ascertain the winner of the
election. I'm not supposed to impose the winner
on the country. And because it was contested.
It was not totally clear to me that I could
ascertain the winner yet, but now I have
and she's tried to kind of pull herself out of
this as a partizan actor. It's basically B.S.
historically, with the exception of the year
2000, where it really did depend on one recount
in one state and it took about a month for that
to be formally recognized. It's pretty clear
that there has been an apparent winner and there
was no reason whatsoever that Emily Murphy should
not have done this earlier. And in the 21st
century, you know, at this point in time,
the longest it should really take to ascertain the
winner of an election is a few days. And that's
what it took. Within a few days, it was clear that
Joe Biden was going to be the next president. So I
do think it would be I mean, listen, this is
a reminder of what this reminds us, that we
have certain checks and balances in this country
that work OK, as long as you don't have anybody
violating the obvious norms. And Donald Trump,
if he did anything, is he went against all of the
norms, you know, Hatch Act sharing classified
information, all of these different things.
So what we've learned is you could have someone as
whacked as Trump that doesn't abide by the norms.
And then you can have a situation where
Emily Murphy spends almost a month
before formally authorizing the transition. It's
sort of a microcosm of the Trump presidency.
We probably should have some more concrete
requirements for the GSA right now. Again, it says
the GSA should ascertain the winner
of the election. It doesn't say how
typically, you know, the media calls the race and
that's not official. It's not official until the
electors actually vote. But the GSA goes with
it and the process begins. But there's nothing
in the law that explicitly says that that's
how it has to happen. So I would like to see
something made more explicit. Again, it wouldn't
have prevented Biden from becoming president.
He would have anyway. But she certainly was
able to gum up elements of the transition and
you could spell it out much more specifically.
That's my thought. The important point is the
transition doesn't actually depend on the
current administration. They certainly can
get in the way of some funding for the transition.
But ultimately, the presidency would end and Joe
Biden would become president regardless on January
20th. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joint Pakman Dotcom.